[Music]
overseas now there are new questions
tonight about how North Korea has been
affected by the corona virus they come
amid confusion over the health of that
country's dictator senior foreign
affairs correspondent Greg Powell Cod
has the story
the mystery of kovat 19 in North Korea
continues despite being surrounded by
countries which had been infested with a
corona virus North Korea a nation with
one of the worst health systems in the
world has said publicly it had zero
cases they are strictly re-examining if
there is any place where infection can
get in and taking precautions according
to a well thought-out plan but recently
it's emerged internal lectures being
given to the North's people by the
government have indicated there are
infections around the country this
confirms reports of deaths among
soldiers prison inmates even those in
Pyongyang all this despite the
government sealing off borders and
launching tough measures aimed at saving
lives and perhaps saving the Kim jong-un
regime but the regime is doing I'm a pro
team of saying acting as if its survival
is threatened by those moves impacting
the North's weak economy and fragile
society could further destabilize the
nuclear-armed rogue nation as for Kim
Jong Moon reported to have had a heart
operation and possibly a better recovery
president Trump thinks he's alright I
have a good relationship with Kim
jong-un and I hope he's okay and other
US officials said Kim was in control
leading some to think this latest
two-week absence might not have anything
to do with an operation it's suggested
by some the chairman Kim might just be
sheltering in place outside of Pyongyang
is it the third time he's gone missing
during this pandemic Brett Gregg thank
you